ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON BETWEEN.
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
LOOSE. ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO C. ARTURO
SMITH STONE THING CALAVERAS BE
APPROVED BY VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER WICKS WOULD MISTER.
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NO. THANK YOU.
PLEASE JOIN ME DEAR LORD WE
THANK YOU FOR ANOTHER DAY TO
WORK FROM CONSTITUENTS
COMMUNITIES IN THIS BEAUTIFUL
STATE. RAIDED YOU MAY BE WITH
US TODAY AND WE WERE TO CREATE
A BETTER CALIFORNIA. AND TO
REPRESENT IN FIFE ALL
CALIFORNIANS COVER US YOUR
STRENGTH AND WISDOM AS WE LEAD
AND THE YOUR CONTROL. CHECK
THIS GUIDED IN EVERY WE DO.
PLEASE BE US WITH EACH OF US AS
WE TRAVEL BACK HOME TO OUR
FAMILY AND CONSTITUENTS YOUR
NAME EMAIL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER AT ALL. I YOU
MISTER SPEAKER PLACE YOUR RIGHT
HAND OVER YOUR HEART. READY
BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. IF. OKAY. FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
MONDAY APRIL NINETEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY MINUTE
ONE PM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE YOU'LL BE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
C. PARKER DESPERATE THEIR PAPER
ONLY READ THE RULES CALL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH MOVEMENT
RARE SMOOTH AND MISS FLOW.
SECONDS. THAT THE READING OF
THE PRE DAY'S. BE WITH PRESENT.
AND PETITION. THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION READ A BILL WILL
BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND DEEMED IT MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVIE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. MEMBERS ARE MOVING
TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MS REYES
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON TO HAVE HIS
DAUGHTER SEATED AT HIS DESK
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
pASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
QUIRK SILVA AND GREAT TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW AB FIVE OH TWO DAVIES
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO SECOND
READING. THE BILL IS NO LONGER
FISCAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL. TWELVE
THIRTY THREE THREE OH NINE
THREE TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO
THREE THIRTY FOUR IT'LL
387-388-1913 962-992-1002
295-114-0411 491-164-1170.
THREE ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
TWELVE TWENTY TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
THIRTEEN FIFTY TO THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR FOURTEEN FIFTY TO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN ELEVEN
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THREE TWO SIX FOUR
FORTY THREE FOUR FORTY FIVE
FIVE OF SIX SIX FORTY ONE SIX
NINETY SEVEN. TEN TWENTY
NINETEEN FORTY THREE TWELVE
FIFTY NINE TWELVE SIXTY TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE FIFTEEN NINETY THREE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY
ONE. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS FORTY SEVEN. THROUGH
FIFTY. PASS RETAIN. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE. AB
SIX FIFTY TWO FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THIS
FRIEDMAN ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO WHICH PROHIBITS
THE INCLUSION OF P. FAST
CHEMICALS IN A WIDE RANGE OF
CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS. BASED ON
CONCERNS FROM THE COMEDIAN
INDUSTRY THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD
ACCEPT MEDICAL DEVICES ADULT
MATTRESSES AND ELECTRONICS
PRODUCTS FROM THE DEFINITION OF
JUVENILE PRODUCT AND EXEMPTS
INTERNAL COMPONENTS OF JUVENILE
PRODUCTS THAT DON'T COME IN
CONTACT WITH THE CHILD SKIN.
AND REQUIRE A MANUFACTURER TO
USE THE LEAST TOXIC ALTERNATIVE
FORMER POLICE REPLACING PEOPLE
ASK CHEMICALS WITHOUT I REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISREAD.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. HI
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT IN THEM SERVED UP BILLS ARE
THE PRINTER BACK ON. FILE ITEM
FIFTH TWO THROUGH FOR FOUR. AND
RETAIN FILE ITEM FIVE. IS AB
SEVENTY BY MISTER SAWYER.
OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY ONE BIAS MEMBER SAWYER
AND I IN ACT RELATING TO
MOBILITY DEVICES MISTER JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE FOR AB THREE
SEVEN ONE WHICH EXTENDS
EXISTING LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
TO PEDESTRIANS IF THEY'RE
INJURED BY ELECTRIC SCOOTER
ELECTRIC BIKE COLLECTIVELY E.
DEVICES. THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE ADDITION OF
BRAILLE AND TACTILE LET US. TO
THESE DEVICE SO NON VISUAL
PEDESTRIANS HAVE CONTACT
INFORMATION TO FILE AN INJURY
REPORT IF THEY EXPERIENCED AN
ACCIDENT SUCH AS TRIPPING OVER
AN ABANDONED P. DEVICE ON THE
SIDEWALK. MY FIRST APPROACHED
BY THE BILL'S SPONSOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF BLIND I
NEED TO REACH OUT TO MY BROTHER
DR FRED JONES AS HE IS ALSO NON
VISUAL. I RECALL A TIME WHEN I
HELPED MY BROTHER. INTO A
BATHROOM WHEN I GOT MARRIED.
LIKE TO NOTE THAT RECENT
AMENDMENTS ADDED DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL AS
ENSURE THAT. INSURANCE CARRIERS
WHO PROVIDE THIS COVERAGE WILL
BE ABLE TO DO SO BY THE TIME OF
ENACTMENT. AN EXAMPLE OF THE
INDUSTRY'S ABILITY TO BROAD
COVERAGE FOR EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION MODELS I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT THE
PARENT COMPANIES OF MANY OF THE
DEVICE PROVIDERS RELIED ON ON
THE SAME INSURANCE CARRIERS. TO
CREATE AND PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL WHEN THEY
FIRST. BEGAN OPERATIONS FURTHER
AND PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANT. TO
ENSURE LIABILITY WOULDN'T
WHAT'S THIS WHICH NOT SOLELY.
FALL ON THE KEY DEVICE
PROVIDERS FOR INJURIES AND
DAMAGES CAUSED BY USERS
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN AND
PREVIOUS COMMITTEES TO
INDEMNIFY. TO INDEMNIFY
PROVIDERS FOR USER NEGLIGENCE.
SUCH AS INTOXICATED RIDING ARE
TEXTING WHILE RIDING THE
SCOOTERS. IT'S ABOUT ENSURING
THAT THE USER HAS LIABILITY AND
NOT THE COMPANY AB THREE SEVEN
ONE REMOVES THE BURDEN OF
RESPONSIBILITY AWAY FROM
ACCIDENT VICTIMS BY ENSURING
PEDESTRIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO ARE NOT VISUAL THE ELDERLY
AND THOSE WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE A METHOD TO BE COMPENSATED
IF INSURED BY IMPROPER USE OF
STORAGE DEVICES. IN ADDITION BY
STAFF HAS FOUND THAT MANY OF
YOU ON THIS FLOOR HAVE ASKED ME.
IS THEIR INSURANCE PROVIDER
WE'VE PROVIDED TO INSURANCE
PROVIDERS. MIGHT NOT BE MY
STAFF HAS BEEN ABLE TO FIND TO
INSURANCE PROVIDERS AND I WHAT
I LIKE THE INDUSTRY TO DO. UBER
AND LIFT THE PARENT COMPANY'S
IN THE OTHERS IS TO COME TO ME
COULD YOU DO NOT WANT. YOU DO
NOT WANT TO DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE OR GOVERNMENT THIS
SET BACK INSURANCE RATE AND SO
I WILL WORK WITH THEM IF THE
BILL MOVES OUT HERE WE GET TO
THE OTHER HOUSE. TO NOT ONLY IN
PUT IN LANGUAGE THAT GIVES HIM
SOME COMFORT THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE LIABLE FOR. BUT
MOST IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
INSURANCE VEHICLE THAT WON'T
BANKRUPT. THAT IT WILL BE
WITHIN SOME GOOD GUIDELINES
THAT MAKES SENSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISS
CHANCELLOR'S. USE SEEING MR
FRAZIER WITH HIS MICROPHONE UP
THIS FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE LOOKED AT IN THIS BILL IS
THE OPPORTUNITY AND IT'S THE
SAME MODEL AS THE RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES WHERE THE USER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY DAMAGE OR
ANY KIND OF- OF NEGLIGENCE OR
WHATEVER. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO
CREATE A HOPE THE AUTHOR IS
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND ON
THIS IS NOT CREATE A MONOPOLY
ON ENSURING THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY THAT THERE ARE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE GOING FORWARD BUT
AGAIN WE ALREADY HAVE A MODEL.
IT'S AN APP BASED KIND OF
PROGRAM THEY CAN OPT OUT OR OPT
FOR BUT ULTIMATELY THE USER
SHOULD BE THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY. GOING FORWARD IN ANY OF
THESE APPLICATIONS I REQUEST
ARRIVAL WITH THAT CABBIE OUGHT
THAT THEY GO THROUGH AND THE
AUTHOR MAKES OF THE EFFORTS TO
VERY CLEARLY DEFINING INTENT.
THANK YOU. THANK U. S. FRAZIER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISTER JONES
SAWYER YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH THANK YOU AND WITH THE
WISE ADVICE OF THE FORMER CHAIR
OF TRANSPORTATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. AND WITH A COUPLE OF THE
ROLE. THE DESIGNED ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN OF A.
ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESERT OF A.
MISTER JONES SAWYER WITH THE
CALL. FILE ITEMS FIFTY SIX
THROUGH SIXTY FOUR. PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE. AB TWO EIGHTY SIX BY MS
GONZALES. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS MS GONZALEZ THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO EIGHTY
SIX DOES TWO THINGS ONE IT
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY FOR BOTH
RESTAURANTS AND CONSUMERS AND
LET ME EXPLAIN WHEN YOU GET A
APP BASED DELIVERY JUST EXPLAIN
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR
RESTAURANTS WE GOT A STORY OUT
OF SANTA BARBARA. OF A MAN WHO
HAS A PIZZA PARLOR IN HE
ACTUALLY ORDERED HIS OWN PIZZA
TO FIND OUT THAT THEY WERE
CHARGING TEN DOLLARS MORE FOR
THE PIZZA THEN HE CHARGES AT
HIS STORE THERE'S NO
TRANSPARENCY RIGHT NOW FOR
RESTAURANTS FOR CONSUMERS ABOUT
HOW MUCH THE COST ATTRACT THE
PAIN ON DELIVERY AND WHERE
THOSE COSTS ARE HIDDEN. THE
OTHER THING THIS BILL DOES IS
IT ENSURES THAT TIPS THAT ARE
GIVEN- BY A CUSTOMER ARE
ACTUALLY DELIVERED TO THE-
WORKER DOING THE WORK SO
THERE'S BEEN EXAMPLES
UNFORTUNATELY OF COMPANIES-
TAKING THEIR DRIVER STEPS IN
THIS WOULD JUST ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO THEIR TIPS
LIKE THEY WOULD IN ANY OTHER
JOB. THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN THEIR LOCAL
CHAMBERS HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FALLING
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN PRIVACY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ.
MR LEE YOUR RECOGNIZE. MR LEE
SURELY YOU ARE READY TO GO
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHT SIX WHICH I'M A PROUD
JOIN AUTHOR OF IT'S IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS PANDEMIC
RIGHT NOW THAT WE'RE DOING ALL
WE CAN TO PROTECT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHAT'S IS APPOINTING
THAT THE FEE CAP WHICH HAS BEEN
ADOPTED BY MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
PROTECT SMALL BUSINESSES WAS
NOT ADVANCE IN THIS MEASURE IT
STILL HAS A VERY IMPORTANT FEE
DISCLOSURES AND MAKING FOR THE
TIPS GET TO WORKERS AND THE
RESTAURANTS AS WELL. SO WE WENT
MEET WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WE RECOVER AT THIS PANDEMIC AND
MAKING SURE THAT BIG TECH
PLATFORMS ARE NOT MONOPOLIZING
THEM ESSENTIALLY AS THEY MUST
ADAPT TO THIS NEW ONLINE
ENVIRONMENT IS SO IMPORTANT I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS.
VERY IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASHLEE. SEEING NO.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM. CARCLUB THEY'RE
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS ABOUT IT IS
THAT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF
THE RESULT OF A. CLARK WELL.
CLOSEROLL TIDE OF THAT ICE
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS SEVEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX AND SIXTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN. FILE ITEM. SIXTY EIGHT.
IS AB THIRTY NINE BY MISTER
CHOW CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO AN ACT RELATING TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. MR SHOP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTY NINE WOULD CODIFY AND
RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA CHINA
CLIMATE INSTITUTE TO ACCELERATE
CLIMATE ACTION THROUGH
COOPERATIVE EFFORTS AND
EXCHANGES. BETWEEN TWO OF THE
WORLD'S LARGEST ECONOMIC POWERS
AND MAJOR EMITTERS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES CALIFORNIA AND
CHINA. CHINA CURRENTLY ADMITS
28% OF THE WORLD'S CARBON
DIOXIDE BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROXIMITY TO CHINA IT BENEFITS
OUR STATE GREATLY OF CHINA IS
ABLE TO REDUCE IS GHG
EMISSIONS. ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION LOS
ANGELES COUNTY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS THE SMOGGIEST OF
METRO AREA IN THE COUNTRY FOR
THE TWENTY FIRST TIME IN TWENTY
TWO YEARS. NINE OF THE TEN
SMOGGIEST COUNTIES IN THE
COUNTRY ARE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
SAMPOERNA DINO RIVERSIDE AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTIES BEING THE
FIRST SECOND AND THIRD WORST IN
THE NATION. TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND REDUCE
EMISSIONS WE MUST ALSO HAVE
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS AROUND THE
WORLD. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN FORMER CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
HELPED LAUNCH THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA INSTITUTE. TO PROMOTE
CLIMATE ACTION THROUGH JOINT
RESEARCH TRAINING AND DIALOGUE
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND CHINA.
THE INSTITUTE IS PARTNERING
WITH LEADING ACADEMIC AND
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES IN CHINA
AND PROVIDING A PLATFORM TO
BUILD THESE URGENTLY NEEDED
PARTNERSHIPS. THE INSTITUTE
ADVANCES JOINT POLICY RESEARCH
ON MAJOR CLIMATE ISSUES
INCLUDING LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION IN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES CARBON PRICING CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
SUSTAINABLE LAND USE AND
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE.
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE AND
AND POLICY ENFORCEMENT. I
PASSING AB THIRTY NINE AND
FORMALIZING THE INSTITUTE IN
STATE LAW THE LEGISLATURE CAN
SEND A POWERFUL MESSAGE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE WAY TO REVERSE CLIMATE
CHANGE BY ADVANCING JOIN
CLIMATE RESEARCH THROUGH
COLLABORATION. THROUGH THE
INSTITUTE. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR CHILD. MR LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HI I HAVE. RISE IN OPPOSITION
NOT BECAUSEIT'S UNNECESSARY
WHICH IT IS UC CAN CONTINUE
DOING WHATEVER PARTNERSHIPS IT
WANTS REGARDLESS OF TODAY'S
ACTION. I'M I'M RISING BECAUSE
IT IS- CONDONING I IN DOING
THIS PARTNERSHIP. WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CHINA TODAY. THAT
A STATE THAT IS FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IS A
LEADER ON SO MUCH THAT WE LEAD
ON VALUES IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT. WE WANT TO CODIFY IN LAW
A PARTNERSHIP. WITH A COUNTRY
THAT UNDER THE PAST PRESIDENT
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO HAD
DESCRIBED WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO
UIGHUR MINORITIES. THREE
MILLION IN SLAVE IMPRISONED IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. WOMEN
FORCIBLY STERILIZED TAKEN FROM
THEIR HOMES. THAT MIGHT COMPEL
CALL THAT GENOCIDE AND THAT NOW
UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN SECRETARY
BLANK AND HAS ALSO DESCRIBED.
AS GENOCIDE. THIS IS NOT AN
ORDINARY BILL. WE PASS EVERY
YEAR HOW MANY BILLS NO
MORALIZING A GENOCIDE THAT HAD
OCCURRED IN THE PAST HOW MANY
RESOLUTIONS SYMBOLIC IN NATURE
PERFORMATIVE AT BEST AND THEN
HERE WE ARE. MIGHTY CALIFORNIA
WE KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
CHINA RIGHT NOW. WE KNOW WHAT
IS OCCURRING TO WOMEN AND MEN
THAT ARE THERE AS SLAVES. AND
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH WE HAVEN'T
KNOWN ABOUT GENOCIDES IN THE
PAST AND DONE NOTHING AS WELL.
ON YOM HASHOAH HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY SECRETARY
BLINKING TALKED ABOUT HOW
LEADERS IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY TRIED TO SCRUB AWAY
THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF THE
HOLOCAUST SO THAT THEY COULD
NOT HAVE IT BE SIGNED ON TO
LEADERS IN OUR COUNTRY. BUT
HERE WE ACTUALLY DO KNOW IT. SO
WILL THIS JUST BE ANOTHER
BENIGN BILL. THAT'S NOT
NECESSARY THAT WE PASS AND THAT
THE WORLD WATCHES AND SAYS.
WHAT DID CALIFORNIA DO WHAT DID
ANY NATION DO WHEN THEY KNEW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN CHINA.
ARE WE JUST GOING TO RUBBER
STAMP THIS. RIGHT NOW IT'S
NIGHT TIME IN JOHN J. WORTH
THREE MILLION PEOPLE ARE
IMPRISONED. AND THERE IS A
YOUNG LADY THERE WHO IS AFRAID
FOR HER LIFE. AND SHE'S
WONDERING IF SOMEONE SOMEWHERE
IN A DISTANT CAPITAL HERE'S HER
CRISIS. I HEAR HER CRIES. BUT
YOU KNOW WHO'S LISTENING TO
THIS RIGHT NOW AND THIS IS THE
SCARY THING. CHINA BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT WHEN WE RUBBER STAMP
THIS THEY CAN CONTINUE TO GET
AWAY WITH IMPRISONING UIGHURS.
AND DOING MEDICAL. EXAM YEAH OF.
FORCIBLY STERILIZING WOMEN AND
WE WILL JUST CONTINUE TO VOTE
FOR PARTNERSHIPS WITH THEM NO
NO NO NO NO I AM DONE WITH
THESE RESOLUTIONS CONDEMNING
ATROCITIES NOW IT'S TIME FOR US
TO ACTUALLY USE OUR VOTES TO
SAY NEVER AGAIN WE ARE NOT
RUBBER STAMPING WE WILL WE DO
NOT NEED TO REQUIRE THIS IN LAW
IT DOES NOT NEED TO BE REQUIRED.
IT CAN GO ON MAYBE IT SHOULDN'T.
BUT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THIS
BILL PLEASE JOIN ME IN VOTING
NOW. THANK YOU MR LEVINE SAYING
NO. ADDITIONAL DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. MR SHOUT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
SPEAKER I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
MY COLLEAGUES POSITION AND
SENTIMENT AND I'M SURE THAT
CHINA IS POLICIES THAT NOT ALL
OF US AGREE WITH. BUT YET I
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
ISOLATE AND SEPARATE ISSUES AND
IDENTIFY THE ONES THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THEM ON AND CLIMATE
CHANGE IS DEFINITELY ONE OF
THEM. WHICH IS ALSO IN LINE
WITH WHAT THE BITING
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA AND AS I STATED
IN MY OPENING REMARKS- CHINA
CURRENTLY IN ITS 20% OF THE
WORLD'S CARBON DIOXIDE. END UP.
THAT TRANSLATES TO ABOUT TEN
BILLION. METRIC TONS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE IN THE AIR THAT'S WHAT
WOOD BRIEFING TODAY. STILL THE
SOONER THEY CAN GET THAT NUMBER
DOWN THE SOONER WE CAN BE THERE
CLEANER AIR. SO WE HAVE A
VESTED INTEREST IN HELPING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. SO WE GOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. HEY
MICHELLE AND WITH THAT CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS AT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
YEAH
THE CALL. MISTER SHALL MOVE THE
CALL. I CAN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE THROUGH. EIGHTY
ONE ASCERTAIN. WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO. AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT BY MR MAYES. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AN
ACCOLADE IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MR MAYS YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT IS RATHER
SIMPLE AND STRIKES AT THE CORE
OF OUR DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS.
WE MUST ENSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE STRUCTURED IN A
WAY THAT LEADS TO THE BEST
ELECTED REPRESENTATION
POSSIBLE. THIS BILL GUARANTEES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
STAND FOR RE ELECTION AND GAIN
EXPERTISE ON THE JOB THROUGH A
MINIMUM OF TWO ELECTED TERMS IN
OFFICE. WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THEM ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION IS LAID OUT IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION SO WE
HAVE QUALIFIED CANDIDATES FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE THAT ARE NOT
JUST INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY. LET
ME BE CLEAR. AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT DOES NOT CONTAIN A
RETROACTIVE CLAUSE NOR WILL I
ALLOW ONE TO BE AMENDED INTO
THE BILL. THEREFORE THIS BILL
DOES NOT DIRECTLY OVERTURN ANY
LOCAL MEASURE NOR IS IT
SUPPOSED TO. HOWEVER A RECENT
LOCAL MEASURE HIGHLIGHTED A
DEFICIENCY IN STATE LAW THAT WE
MUST ADDRESS RESULTING IN THIS
BILL BEFORE US TODAY THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY LABOR AND PUBLIC
SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS. AS WELL
AS ALL THREE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WOULD REPRESENT ALL THE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE. THANK
YOU MISTER MESS. MR GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YEAH THANK
YOU MEMBERS IT AND MISTER
SPEAKER- YEAH THIS BILL IS NOT
RETROACTIVE- I AGREE WITH THAT
BUT I DON'T I DON'T SEE WHY WE
SHOULD PROACTIVELY HERE. GOING
INTO THE FUTURE TELL LOCAL
VOTERS WHAT THEY SHOULD DO WITH
REGARD TO THEIR LOCAL ELECTED
THEIR LOCAL ELECTED. AND WHAT
TYPE OF TERM LIMITS THEY SHOULD
HAVE. IS NOT FOR US OF THE
STATE TO DETERMINE THOSE THINGS
RIGHT. IT SHOULD BE UP TO LOCAL
VOTERS TO DETERMINE WHAT THEY
WANT IN TERMS OF. THE TERM
LIMITS THE PAY THE COMPENSATION-
AND WHATEVER LOCAL RULES THAT
THEY WANT TO IMPLEMENT CAMPAIGN
FINANCE RULES FOR INSTANCE-
THAT THEY WANT TO IMPLEMENT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. FOR THEIR
LOCAL ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
IT SHOULD BE US AT THE STATE
LEVEL TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO.
AND THAT'S WHY I WOULD ASK THAT
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL TODAY THANK
YOU. THEY WERE SKELETOR MISTER
RAMOS YOU HAVE RECOGNIZE FROM
HER DESK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO RISE IN. STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- I
SPOKE UP AGAINST HIS BILL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- WITH THE AUTHOR-
CONTINUE. TO OFFER TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE DIALOGUE. THERE'S TWO
COMPONENTS IN THIS BILL ONE
DEALS WITH THE TERM LIMITS IN
THAT PART OF THE BILL TALKS
ABOUT GOING BACK INTO THE
ELECTORATE. THERE'S A SECOND
PART OF THE BILL THAT HAS
CAUSED ME GREAT CONCERN. IN
THAT SECTION TWO. THAT ADS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY. TO
THE COUNTY BOARD THE COUNTY
BOARD AUTHORITY TO SET THEIR
OWN SALARY. IN SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY CURRENTLY THERE'S BEEN
THREE REFERENDUMS THAT HAVE
DEALT WITH TERM LIMITS. AND
SALARIES CURRENTLY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS RECEIVED PLUS
BENEFITS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WELL THE
EMPLOYEES AND FAMILIES IN
SEMINOLE COUNTY LIVE FAR BELOW
THAT AVERAGE ANNUAL INCOME.
ALLOWING THOSE TO SET THEIR OWN
SALARY IN ANY BUSINESS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO. AND NOT
ONLY THAT. THAT WE ALSO SEE
THAT THE VOTERS OF SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY VOTED SIXTY SIX PERCENT.
ON THIS ISSUE OF TERM LIMITS
AND SALARY AND IT WASN'T THE
FIRST TIME. THERE IS A SERIES
OF ELECTION SERIES OF
REFERENDUMS FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE. TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. N. NOW
BECAUSE IT'S NOT WORKING OUT IN
THE WAY THAT SOME WOULD LIKE.
COME TO THE STATE THIS IS A
LOCAL ISSUE AT ITS FINEST HOUR
THIS IS A LOCAL ISSUE THAT
SHOULD GO BACK. TO THE VOTE OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE REPRESENTED BECAUSE AFTER
ALL. IS THAT GENERAL FUND
THAT'S PAYING THE SALARIES THE
SALARIES OF EMPLOYEES THE
SALARIES OF ALL THOSE THAT ARE
OUT THERE. AND IT ALSO IS THEIR
VOICE THAT WAS HEARD WITH
OVERWHELMING OVER WHILE MEAN
PARTICIPATION OF 77% OF THE
LECTERN. THE OF THE AUTHOR WILL
SAY THIS HAS NO BEARING ON
OVERTURNING THAT REFERENDUM
HOWEVER IF THIS BILL DOES MOVE
FORWARD IT WILL BECOME THE LAW
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ELECTIONS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AND URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
STAND WITH ME ON THIS. BAKER
WAS WRONG NEVER. PLEASE KEEP
YOUR CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM.
PLEASE THE RETENTION OF HIS
RACE WAS RAMPS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER
I REGRETTABLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. FOR ME
THIS IS A BILL THAT
SPECIFICALLY AFFECTS THE VOTERS
IN MY DISTRICT AND IN GREATER
SAMBAR TO DINO COUNTY IT
AFFECTS THE VALUE OF THEIR VOTE.
AB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT WOULD UNDO
THE WILL OF THE VOTERS IN ST
BERNARD DINO COUNTY WHO JUST
LAST YEAR IS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HIGHLAND NOTED. JUST LAST YEAR
VOTED TO APPROVE MEASURE K. BY
A TWO THIRDS MARGIN WHICH
PLACES TERM AND SALARY LIMITS
ON MEMBERS OF THE SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY IS THE
ONLY COUNTY IN WHICH THE VOTERS
SPECIFICALLY VOTED ON THESE
ISSUES. ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
WOULD APPEAR TO BE BROADER IT
IS CLEAR THAT THIS BILL AFFECTS
THE VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE RELATED
TO THE COUNTY OF SAN BERNADINO.
WHILE I MAY AGREE WITH SOME OF
THE ARGUMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. AS
TO WHY SUCH LIMITED TERMS IN
PUBLIC OFFICE WOULD AFFECT OUR
GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE. I MUST
OPPOSE BECAUSE THIS WOULD UNDO
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
OFTEN FEEL. THEY ARE WITHOUT A
VOICE THIS BILL SENDS A MESSAGE
TO PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT THAT
IN SPITE OF THEIR OVERWHELMING
VOTE THE STATE LEGISLATURE'S
GOING TO REVERSE THEIR DECISION
WITHOUT ANY INPUT OF THE
COMMUNITY NOR AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR A NEW ELECTION TO REVISIT
AND DECIDE THE ISSUE A NEW. IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS BUT I MUST
RISE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MISS REYES MISTER MATHIS WE ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I I'VE LOOKED AT THE BILL
I'VE LOOKED AT A DIFFERENT
WAYS- BUT I REALLY WANT TO READ
FROM ALL RC RC FROM A RURAL
COUNTIES- BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
I'M FROM THAT'S WHAT I
REPRESENT AND I THINK WHAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY IS IMPORTANT HERE.
SAYS WRITING TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT. FOR ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
ENSURE. THAT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
TERM LIMITS. ARE LIMITED TO NO
FEWER. THEN TO TERMS. MEMBERS
MANY OF US CAME IN WHEN TERM
LIMITS CHANGED WE SAW A DROP IN
SHRINK OUR STATE LOST ABILITY.
THE PEOPLE LOST POWER THIS IS
JUST TRYING TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COUNTY SUPERVISORS HAVE
LONGEVITY. THAT THAT KNOWLEDGE
STAYS THERE. IN THAT ARE
COUNTIES CAN MAINTAIN STRONG
WITH THAT I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. MR MAYS YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- AND
MEMBERS I REALLY GENUINELY
ENJOY THE DEBATE IN FACT I KNOW
HERE ON THE FLOOR A WE OFTEN
DON'T DEBATE THE ISSUES I'M SO
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
ESPECIALLY- IN THE COMMENTS OF
MY TWO COLLEAGUES FROM SENATOR
DINO- I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH
THEM- ON. ON THEIR ON THEIR
CONCERNS THAT THE DIFFICULTY-
FOR ME IS. THE BILL IS VERY
SIMPLE IN FACT THERE IS ONLY
TWO PARTS ONE DEALING WITH TERM
LIMITS AND THE SECOND ONE IS
DEALING WITH HEY. LET ME DEAL
WITH THE PAY QUESTION FIRST THE
PAY QUESTION. IS AND I DON'T
I'VE NEVER VOTED FOR A BILL IT
SAID ITS DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW THIS JUST
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW AND
CLARIFIES WHAT IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION. IN ARTICLE ELEVEN
SECTION ONE IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
VERY CLEAR SO THE STATUTE IS
JUST CLARIFIES THAT SO LET'S
DISPENSE WITH THE SECOND THE
SECOND PART OF IT THE FIRST THE
FIRST PART OF IT. IS IN REGARDS
TO TERM LIMITS. AND ALTHOUGH A
MY CALL IT COLLEAGUES FROM JUST
UP THE ROAD HERE IT HAD SAID
THAT WE SHOULDN'T LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR LOCAL VOTERS TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT I THINK ALL OF
US AGREE. HERE IN THIS BUILDING
THAT WHEN WE ARE AT SIX YEAR
TERMS. FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MAXIMO SIX YEARS IT WAS A
DISASTER. AN ABSOLUTE DISASTER
AND THAT TWELVE YEARS IS A MUCH
BETTER AMOUNT OF TIME THIS BILL
SAYS THAT YOU GET. TO TERMS A
MINIMUM OF TWO TERMS EIGHT
YEARS AND THE VOTERS CAN STILL
DO TERM LIMITS IT'S JUST THAT
THEY GET. TO TERMS THE VERY
VERY SIMPLE MEASURE REGARDING
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THIS BILL
GETS OUT TODAY WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU. I TO BE
ABLE TO MEND IT WHEN HE GETS
OVER THE SENATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESPECTED ACOSTA NINE. AND
WITH THAT THE CLERK CALLED THE
ROLL. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TADARISE FORTY ONE KNOWS TEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY THREE THROUGH EIGHTY
NINE. PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY AB AND TEN
SIXTY ONE BY MR LEE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AN ACT
RELATING TO MOBILE HOMES MISTER
LEE YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TEN
SIXTY ONE WERE PROTECT MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS FROM UNFAIR
WATER SERVICE CHARGES CURRENTLY
MANY RESIDENTS ARE CHARGED IN
BIGGEST WATER SERVICE FEES THAT
OFTEN INCREASES WITHOUT ANY
EXPLANATION OVER HALF OF MOBILE
HOME HOUSEHOLDS EARN LESS THAN
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
AND MANY RESIDENTS ARE ON FIXED
INCOME SO THESE FEES CAN ADD UP
AND BE BURDENSOME WE ADDRESS
SEVERAL OF THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS NEW AMENDMENTS THE
BILL NOW ALLOWS PARK OWNERS TO
BE REIMBURSED FOR HIGHER WATER
PRICES THEY MAY PAY DUE TO
TIERED BILLING. IT ALSO ALLOWS
PARK OWNERS TO INCLUDE RESULT
MANAGEMENT AND BILLING COSTS ON
THE WATER BILL THIS BILL DOES
NOT DOES NOT PREVENT PARK
OWNERS FROM RECOUPING COSTS
THEY INCUR WHEN PROVIDING
RESIDENTS WITH WATER AB TEN
SIXTY ONE WILL ENSURE THEIR
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS ARE NOT
PROFITEERING OFF THEIR
RESIDENTS SIMPLY I RESPECT LEE
ASTER I'VE OF. FAVORS SAID. NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
HE SAID ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A
MICHELINE
MOVES A CALL. FILE ITEMS NINETY
ONE THROUGH. NINETY FIVE. PASS
AND RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NINETY SIX A. B. TWO EIGHTY
NINE FIVE MS CALDERON. MEMBERS.
LOCAL RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON OF ACTIVATING THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY NINE SEEKS TO ENSURE
FAIRNESS AND SCHOOL DISTRICT
MERIT SYSTEM ELECTIONS EXISTING
LAW AUTHORIZES THE ADOPTION
REMOVAL OF SCHOOL MERIT SYSTEMS
BY MAJORITY VOTE OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. THIS BILL WILL
CODIFY EQUITY FOR THESE
EMPLOYEES DURING MERIT SYSTEM
ELECTIONS AND ADDS IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT TO THE ELECTION
PROCESS. THIS BILLS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS CALDERON.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS THAT OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MY RESULT IN SARAJEVO.
WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS NINETY SEVEN.
THROUGH ONE OH TO PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
OH THREE AB NINE EIGHTY THREE
BY MR GARCIA CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS MR GARCIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
A. B. NINETY THREE THE DISTRICT
BILL THAT FOCUSES ON ENSURING
THAT IMPERIAL COUNTY HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES OUR OUR
ADDRESS BY IMPLEMENTING SEE
WA'S COLM MEANEY WORKFORCE OF
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I THANK
MR SEAH. SENIOR DISCUSSION ON
THE ADAM. CARPAL OF THE WORLD.
THAT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TITLEIST SEVEN KNOWS TEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL ON MR
JONES SAWYER IS ITEM THAT'S
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB THREE
SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO
WISH TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE EYES FORTY SIX
FORTY EIGHT I FORTY EIGHT NO
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES. BACK
IN FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY MISTER CHIU CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AN
ACT RELATING TO MEDICAL
INFORMATION TO SECURE YOUR
MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD STRENGTHEN EXISTING
PATIENT CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE WERE NOT
THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER FOR
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE. CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS A PATIENT TO REQUEST
INFORMATION RELATED TO
SENSITIVE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TO NOT BE SENT TO THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER. THROUGH A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
REQUEST HOWEVER THERE'S BEEN NO
STANDARDIZED PROCESS SO FALTERS
BEEN A HAZARD. AND CAN FILE
COMPLAINT WITH THE STATE IF
COMPANIES FAIL TO ACCOMMODATE
REQUESTS BUT THE DAMAGE HAS
BEEN DONE. THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS FOR
SENSITIVE SERVICES AND EXPAND
THE DEFINITION OF SENSITIVE
SERVICES TO INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE AND TRANSGENDER
HEALTH CARE TO ENSURE MORE
PRIVACY IS PROTECTED. HI WITH
THAT COLLEAGUES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CRITICAL OF THE ROLE. IS THAT
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER TIDE OF THE
EYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS TWELVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSER
RETAINED ON FILE ITEM ONE OF
SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE OH
SEVEN. AB TWELVE NINETY THREE
BY MR COOLEY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO RETIREMENT MR KOHLI
EMAIL BUT- GOOD MORNING MR
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE NINETY THREE.
WHICH ALLOWS A JUDGE AND JUDGES
FOR TERM SYSTEM TO PENSION
SYSTEM TO HAVE THEIR INCOME
LIMIT RETESTED AGAINST. OUR
DEPARTMENT TREASURY GUIDELINES
ANNUALLY. CURRENT FEDERAL LAW
CAPS A PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO FIND
PENSION BENEFIT IS SPECIFIED
DOLLAR AMOUNT. BUT IT ALSO IS
THAT AMOUNT IS INDEXED
PERIODICALLY BY THE TREASURY.
AND GO UNDER STATE LAW STATE
RETIREES GENERALLY WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THE FEDERAL LIMIT.
MAY HAVE THEIR INCOME RETESTED
IN ORDER TO. RECEIVE A SLIGHTLY
HIGHER BENEFIT. OF THIS LAW
HOWEVER DOES NOT APPLY TO THE
SEPARATE JUDGE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM WITH THIS POINT. THIS
BILL EXTEND THIS RETESTED RIGHT
TO JUDGE RETIREMENT TO SYSTEMS.
AND I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN REFERRAL WHO RAISED A
QUESTION. AND REPLY TO THAT I
WILL SAY THAT THIS DOES NOT
BYPASS CAPRA IN ANYWAY SO I
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TO THIS
GOOD BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES. ASSOCIATION
AND HAS HAD UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR COOLEY. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THANK
LIBERAL. THESE ARE NOT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE- DESIRABLE.
WELL THOSE ARE TIDE OF THE I.
SIXTY SEVEN. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OR NINE AB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. MEMBERS. MY ARM IS
SORE FROM THE SHOT PLEASE MAKE
ME STOP GAMBLING. THIS IS MR
VIA PUTIDA. FIVE A ONE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
APPROVED WELL AN ACT RELATING
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THIS REPORT BUT-
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. AB FOURTEEN SEVEN ONE
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
ADVANCES A MORE REGIONAL
DIVERSE APPROACH TO THE
OPERATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
WILL GUARANTEE APPROPRIATE AND
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT FOR THE
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF EVERY
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS EPICALLY AB AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL REQUIRE AT
LEAST ONE CPUC APPOINTEE TO
RESIDE IN EACH OF THE FOLLOWING
AREA. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS SIMILAR TO
THE CURRENT REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA AIR AIR RESOURCE
BOARD. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
WILL ENSURE THE COMMISSION HAS
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH ALL
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA AND WILL
FURTHER GUARANTEE APPROPRIATE
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT FOR EACH
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER YOU PUT
A- SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CARCLUB THE ROLE.
THERE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. OKAY ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL THE I. SIXTY
SIX KNOWS THREE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
ON CALL. FOR PARALYMPIC LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM NINETY
THAT'S AB TEN SIXTY ONE. BY
MISTER LEE. LOCAL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS SHOULD WISH TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
L. EYES FORTY SEVEN NOES THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES. AND I'M
ALSO GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN FILE ORDER. MISTER
MURATSUCHI HAS AN ITEM THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO. AB TWO
SEVENTY NINE FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO AB TWO SEVENTY NINE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO CARE FACILITIES IN
THE CURRENT YEARS EITHER OF
THICK THICK IMMEDIATELY. MR
MURATSUCHI YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND I ARE PRESENTING
AB TWO SEVEN NINE. TO HELP
PROTECT NURSING HOME RESIDENTS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THIS BILL
WILL TEMPORARILY HALT NURSING
HOME EVICTIONS AN INVOLUNTARY
TRANSFERS UNLESS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY DURING THE LIMITED
COVERED NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY PERIOD. SENIORS
LIVING IN NURSING HOMES HAVE
BEEN AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
TO COME OF IT. THEY ACCOUNTED
FOR ALMOST HALF OF ALL DEATHS
DUE TO COLD IN THE EARLY MONTHS
OF THE PANDEMIC. ACCORDING TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES AND OTHER MEDIA
OUTLETS NURSING HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN DUMPING.
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS AND
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND OTHER
UNSAFE FACILITIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
HIGHER MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES AND CALIFORNIA ROCK PORT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
STATE'S LARGEST CHAIN OF FOR
PROFIT NURSING HOMES. HAVE BEEN
REPEATEDLY CITED FOR ILLEGAL
EVICTIONS SO THIS IS NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT FOR WAS THIS
BILL IS DESIGNED FOR AND LOS
ANGELES AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BOYLE HEIGHTS IN LOS ANGELES.
REBECCA ANOTHER OWNER OF THE
FOR PROFIT NURSING HOME CHAIN
HAS STARTED TRANSFERRING
RESIDENCE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
RAGING PANDEMIC SO THAT THEY
CAN CONVERT THE FACILITY INTO
LUXURY APARTMENTS. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
REMOVE ALL OF THEIR TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THE CONCERNS AND I AM
COMMITTING A TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT I'VE DISCUSSED
THIS BILL WITH. TO CONFORM THE
ADVANCE NOTICE PROVISION FROM
SIX MONTHS TO NINETY DAYS AS IT
IS AN EXISTING LAW AND SO YOU
HAVE THAT MY COMMITMENT. THIS
BILL WILL HELP PROTECT
VULNERABLE SENIORS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC FROM BEING EVICTED OR
FROM SUFFERING TRANSFER TRAUMA
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS
MATTEO BY THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT LOCALLY
PROVIDES INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT STATEWIDE
BECAUSE IF IT HAPPENS IN MY
BACKYARD. IT CAN HAPPEN IN YOUR
BACKYARD AS WELL. WE HAVE CLOSE
TO SEVENTY SENIORS. WITH LONG
HISTORIES IN OUR COMMUNITY THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN. THEY WANT TO
REMOVE. THE SENIORS AND PUT
THEM IN ANOTHER FACILITY WHAT
AND WHAT ARE MY SOUND OKAY
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
OTHER FACILITY DURING A
PANDEMIC DURING A GLOBAL CRISIS.
WHAT THOUSAND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN THE AREA
THEY WANT TO MOVE INTO A
LOCATION WHERE OVER A HUNDRED
PEOPLE HAVE DIED ALREADY A
HUNDRED SENIORS. THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THEY'RE DOING. IF IT
HAPPENS IN MY BACKYARD IT CAN
HAPPEN ACOSTA TO CALIFORNIA OUR
SENIORS THOSE WHO RAISE THOSE
THOSE WERE MOST PRIZED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ACOSTA TO
CALIFORNIA WE SAW THIS PANDEMIC
RISE WE SAW. THE INEQUITIES
WHEN IT CAME TO SENIORS AND
SKILLED NURSING HOMES. WE SAW.
WHAT HAPPENED WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN ONE AREA THAT FROM
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LITERALLY TO KICK
OUT SENIORS DURING THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC. ONLY TO MOVE IN
A FACILITY THAT HAD OVER A
HUNDRED SENIORS WHO HAVE DIED.
IT IN HUMANE AND THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW US. TO KEEP OUR
SENIORS WHERE THEIR ADS. THE
ONES WHO RAISE THOSE WHO GAVE
US CULTURE. AND WHO ARE WHO ARE
WHO ARE STILL IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHO MAKE US WHO WE ARE. WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT PROTECTING
SENIORS IN THIS IN THESE
CHAMBERS AND HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THOSE.
SENIOR FOR SAVE THE DAY AND WE
WANT TO KEEP HIM OUT. WILL BE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WE WANT TO
PROTECT OUR SENIORS. IT
HAPPENED IN MY BACKYARD I
MENTIONED WELL WE HAD A N. N.
OR A FACILITY CALLED THE COR
GARDENS. BUT SIXTIES IF SIXTY
SENIORS. AND TO BE FORCED TO
MOVE TO A LOCATION RUBBER
HUNDRED SENIORS HAVE DIED.
THAT'S WHAT WAS DECIDED. WE GOT
TO STOP THIS IT DOESN'T OCCUR
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LET ALONE IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR MINE NOW
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DAMOS SANTIAGO MR VOEPEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY NINE.
L. AS THE VICE CHAIR OF LONG
TERM CARE NAY GENE LET ME PUT A
LITTLE BIT OF A HUMAN FACE ON
THIS. SENIORS THE NURSING HOMES
ARE INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE AND
DURING COALBED WE'VE LOST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PLUS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROTECTS THESE SENIORS KEEP
SOME SAVE UNTIL THE CODE RED
EMERGENCY IS OVER. HELLO PLEASE
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THE
SENIORS. HAVE A DIFFERENT
CULTURE AND WHEN YOU'RE IN A
NURSING HOME YOU HOLD ON TO
WHATEVER LITTLE YOU HAVE LEFT.
AND VISITORS IN HOME IN THIS
CULTURE IT'S ALL THEY'VE GOT.
AND IF YOU MOVE THEM YOU'RE
GOING TO KILL HIM TO SOME
EXTENT. AS MANY TIMES THE
SENIORS. JUST GIVE UP. THANK
YOU. DAVID HOTEL MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- MY
COMMENTS SPOKE SO ELOQUENTLY
THE ONLY THING I'D LIKE TO ADD
IS AS CHAIR OF AGING COMMITTEE
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
ISSUE AND A VERY POINT SERIES
OF ARTICLES THAT WERE WRITTEN
TO EXPOSE ALL OF THESE ISSUES
BY THE L. A. TIMES IN NEW YORK
TIMES. THE ONLY TAKE AWAY YOU
NEED TO LOOK AT IS WHEN ONE OF
THE ARTICLES POINTEDLY STATED.
THAT THE CENTERS HAVE ONLY 1%
LESS THAN 1% OF THE NAY IN TIRE
NATION'S POPULATION. YET DURING
THIS PANDEMIC THE CONTRIBUTED
40% OF THE DEATHS. IF THAT DOES
NOTSPEAK VOLUMES. FOR HOW THIS
INDUSTRY HAS FAILED OUR
SENIORS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WOULD CONVINCE US SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I FIRST WANT TO
GIVE SPECIAL THANKS TO ALL OF
THOSE WHO THAT ROSE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I WANT TO GIVE
SPECIAL THANKS TO MR VOEPEL
SHOWING THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
TO PROTECT OUR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS ARE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS I ALSO WANT TO.
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO REMOVE ALL OF
THEIR CONCERNS OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T WANT TO WE DON'T WANT TO
UNDERMINE THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE BADS THOSE
SERVICES CAN CONTINUE BUT- THIS
IS A LIMITED EMERGENCY MEASURE-
DURING THIS LIMITED STATE OF
EMERGENCY PERIOD. I ASK FOR
IAGO. AND WITH THAT CARPOOL OF
NARAL. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY AS FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES. BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN. AB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
BY MISTER IS AREA. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARIAN
AND ACRYLATE IN THE STREETS
MISTER IS THERE ANYWAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE AUTHORIZES
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO MAKE
TEMPORARY SLOW STREETS
PERMANENT IN ADDITION A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE AUTHORIZES
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO ADOPT A
RULE OR REGULATION TO DESIGNATE
A LOCAL STREET WITHIN ITS
JURISDICTION AS A SLOW ST. THE
TWENTY THE IDEA WAS TO IDENTIFY
STREETS WERE THROUGH TRAFFIC
WOULD BE BANNED LIMITING
STREETS SO PEOPLE COULD USE THE
PAVEMENT FOR EXERCISE AND
RECREATION DURING THE TIME OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS
IMPLEMENTED TEMPORARY PROGRAMS
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THAT HAVE CREATED MORE
THAN FIFTY MILES OF SLOW
STREETS FOR PEOPLE THAT NEED IT
MOST SIMILAR TO OTHER CITIES
ACROSS THE NATION AND ABROAD WE
PURPOSING STREETS TO PRIORITIZE
COMMUNITY NEEDS HAS BEEN A
WINNING CONCEPT CREATING MORE
OPEN SPACE FOR BICYCLING
WALKING. RECREATING WHILE
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FAMILIES TO SPEND TIME THE SLOW
STREETS PROGRAM HAS BEEN MET
WITH AN OVERWHELMING DEMAND
FROM RESIDENTS AND DOZENS OF
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE WAITING ON
LOCAL INSTALLATIONS TO CONTINUE
AND EXPAND THIS PROGRAM AND TO
REALIZE THE FULL LONG TERM
BENEFITS LOW STREETS NEEDS
PERMANENCE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTRESS AREA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CORPORAL.
ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VETERANS AT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIED UP I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS.
ONE TWELVE THROUGH ONE FIFTEEN
PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY MISS IRWIN. I
AGREE ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND AFTER LIVING HEALING
ARTS MEASURE WHEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT WILL AUTHORIZE
PHARMACISTS TO ENGAGE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH ACTIVITIES LIKE HEALTH
SCREENINGS AND ALLOW THEM TO
ADMINISTER MANY CLIA WAIVED
TESTS. PHARMACISTS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM BY
UTILIZING THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY PATIENT CARE.
PHARMACISTS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
PERMITTED TO PROVIDE MORE THAN
A FEW CLIA WAIVED TESTS EVEN
THOUGH THESE TESTS ARE DEFINED
BY THE FDA AS SIMPLE TESTS WITH
A LOW RISK FOR AN INCORRECT
RESULTS. ADDITIONALLY
PHARMACISTS ARE CURRENTLY ONLY
ALLOWED TO PROVIDE HEALTH
SCREENINGS FOR CONDITIONS THAT
ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
MEDICATION REGIMES. THIS FAILS
TO RECOGNIZE THE KEY ROLE
PHARMACISTS CONSERVE TO PREVENT
REDUCE OR MITIGATE PROGRESSION
OF DISEASE BY CONDUCTING
SCREENING IS THAT REFERRING
PATIENTS TO IDENTIFIED HEALTH
ISSUES WITH IDENTIFIED HEALTH
ISSUES WITH POSITION. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT MINIMISES
BARRIERS AND RESTRICTIONS AND
CURRENT LAW BY PERMITTING
PHARMACISTS TO ADMINISTER CLIA
WAIVED TESTS WITH CERTAIN
EXCEPTIONS AND TO NOTIFY THE
PATIENT'S POSITION OF ANY OF
NORMAL RESULTS. IF THE PATIENT
DOES NOT HAVE A PHYSICIAN THE
PHARMACIST WILL PROVIDE THE
PATIENT WITH A LIST OF
PHYSICIANS CLINICS OR OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. WE
EXPAND PROXIMITY TO CARE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF ACUTE AND
CHRONIC DISEASE AND THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE AND
LENGTH OF LIFE WHILE REDUCING
ECONOMIC BURDENS AMENDMENTS AND
VIP THIS TEST THAT PHARMACISTS
WILL NOT PERFORM. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
TODAY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU MR ONE. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CABALLERO
ALL MEMBERS OF THAT AMOUNT. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL. TYLER HIGHS
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTEEN
THROUGH ONE TWENTY THREE PASS.
AND RETAIN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BRIEFLY BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MS
RANGE YOU'RE RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR AB TWELVE
TWENTY ONE FLORA FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND RE REFER
THE BILL TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON
CALL. PREPARE TO LIVE THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM. SIXTY EIGHT AB
THREE NINE MISTER CHAPTER
PROPOSED. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
WHICH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. THE CLARK
WELL. BECAUSE ROLL TIDE OF A
SIZE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS. FIFTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
ARE AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS. ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE
WE VOTE WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP
THE RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUINN
AND OTHERS RELATIVE O A WILL
DIE DAY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
RELATIVE TO LYME DISEASE
AWARENESS MONTH ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL RELATIVE TO STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH WEEK. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER WHEN AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH AND ASSUME THE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
SEA LEVEL RISE AWARENESS MONTH.
WE'LL NOW OPEN THE ROLE. TO ADD
ON AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
RESOLUTION MEMBERS THIS IS. A
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS FOR ADDING YOUR NAME AS A
CO AUTHOR. TO THE RESOLUTION I
CONSENT. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ALL THEIR SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED. NOW MOVING TO A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITSELF DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING HEARING NONE
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
EXACT COUNT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE AN ACT RELATING TO
GUARDIANSHIP. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND VOTE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WELL. CLOSER
ALL THE TIME BUT I SEVENTY FOUR
NO ZERO. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED HER FOR RE READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT
ASSEMBLY ROOM FOUR OH SEVEN
HIGHS SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY RULE FOR TWENTY FIVE
FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SYMBOL FOR SIXTY EIGHT I.
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE FOR SEVENTY TWO I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE THIRTY SIX I SEVENTY
FOUR DOWN ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE EIGHTY I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FORTY
THREE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR TO
ZERO. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY ONE
WITH URGENCY I SEVENTY FOUR
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I
SEVENTY FOUR NOTES HERE ON THE
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY
FOUR EYES SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SEMINAL SEVEN NINETY EIGHT I
SEVENTY FOUR NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY FOUR. SEVENTY FOUR NINE
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN FOUR NINE ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SYMBOL TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR OH ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY THREE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE THIRTEEN FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR I SEVENTY
FOUR TO ZERO SO WE CAN CURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY FIVE FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
TWO. SEVENTY FOUR ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY
EIGHT I. SEVENTY FOUR TO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY NINE I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO SUM THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR ZERO AND ASSEMBLY
BILL. FIFTEEN EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR. NO ZERO.
MEMBERS
WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
REMOVE YOUR CONVERSATIONS FROM.
THE GREEN CARPET. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THIS COURSE. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY FOR SANDRA
FOX SANDRA WAS BORN ON MARCH
SIXTH NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND
WAS A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
ORANGE COUNTY SHE STARTED. AS
AN EMPLOYMENT L. ELIGIBILITY
SPECIALISTS FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE WHO TURNED INTO A LABOR
ACTIVISTS NOT BY CHOICE BUT
BECAUSE SHE SAW A NEED TO STAND
UP. TO STAND UP AGAINST UNSAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND HOW
TAXPAYER MONEY SHOULD BE SPENT
SHE WAS THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
ASKED ME AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES TWENTY SEVENTY SIX
CHAPTER. WHEN YOU THINK OF
ORANGE COUNTY'S JUSTICE
MOVEMENT SANDRA FOX WAS ALWAYS
THERE TO STAND UP AGAINST ALL
ODDS AND RISKS AND SHE STOOD UP
TO HER LAST DAY. THAT WAS
SANDRA SHE WAS AN ADVOCATE SHE
WAS A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WHO
HAD A HUGE HEART AND SHE GAVE
BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY IN SO
MANY WAYS SHE HELPED PEOPLE BY
CONNECTING THEM TO THE RIGHT
NETWORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
RECEIVED THE HELP THEY NEEDED.
SHE WAS BELOVED BY ALL THAT MET
HER AND HOLDS A VERY SPECIAL
SPECIAL PLACE IN THE HEARTS OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY LABOR
FEDERATION. SADLY SHE PASSED
AWAY FROM COMPLICATIONS FROM
COVERT NINETEEN ON FEBRUARY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
SANDRA WAS NOT ONLY AN ADVOCATE
AND A WARRIOR FOR PEOPLE AND
FOR PEOPLE'S RIGHTS BUT SHE WAS
A BELOVED MOTHER. WHO HAD TWO
SONS I REMEMBER HER FACE BUT IT
PH<c.cyan>OSTS WERE ALWAYS ABOUT</c>
CHEERING FOR HER SONS AND OF
COURSE DURING COVERT WAS SO SAD
THAT HER. I KNOW ONE OF HER
SONS WAS NOT ABLE TO PLAY ONE
OF HIS YEARS OF FOOTBALL. SHE
IS SURVIVED BY HER MOTHER FREDA
FOX IN OUR SON'S ELLEN IN DIEGO
TWO GRAND CHILDREN RAN AND MIA
AND HER FIANCE. HER FIANCE
CRAIG OSBORNE IN SANDERS LAST
DAYS SHE WAS SMILING FROM EAR
TO EAR I KNOW SHE WAS SO
EXCITED AS HER LIFE HAD MOVED
FORWARD WITH A NEW RELATIONSHIP
AND SHE JUST WAS BRILLIANT WITH
HAPPINESS SHE WILL BE MISSED
TRULY SHE'S BEEN IN MEYER AND
WE CONTINUE TO MISS HER BUT HER
MEMORY WILL LIVE ON THROUGH
SOCIAL JUSTICE WORK THAT SHE
DID IN ORANGE COUNTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA.
MISTER GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IS WITH GREAT
SORROW TODAY THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF MARIE GALLO.
WITH HER PASSING LAST MONDAY AN
IRREPLACEABLE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN LOST. BREE
WAS THE DAUGHTER OF A PROMINENT
JUDGE FRANK THEM REAL SENIOR
WHO MANY OF YOU IN OUR
COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT
SACRAMENTO NO FROM HIS TIME
HERE. RE WAS A CLASSICALLY
TRAINED PIANIST WHO BECAME A
TEACHER AND IN NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT WED BOB GALLO WHO BY THEN
WAS DESTINED TO BECOME ONE OF
THE COMMUNITIES. MOST PROMINENT
BUSINESSMEN. AS LEADERS OF THE
MOST RENOWNED WINERY IN THE
WORLD BOB AND MARIE GALA COULD
HAVE LIVED ANYWHERE BUT THEY
CHOSE. TO REMAIN IN MODESTO
CLOSE TO THEIR ROOTS THEIR
CHURCH. AND MANY OF THEIR SEVEN
SURVIVING CHILDREN TWENTY TWO
GRANDCHILDREN. RE GALLAGHER
MADE DOWN TO EARTH ACCESSIBLE
AND THOROUGHLY INVOLVED IN THE
COMMUNITY. SHE GAVE GENEROUSLY
BOTH FINANCIALLY WITH HER TIME
AND PASSION TO MAKE MODESTO A
BETTER PLACE TO LIVE. RE WAS
THE DRIVING FORCE BEHIND THE
CREATION AND OPERATION OF THE
GALLO CENTER FOR THE ARTS WHICH
HAS BECOME AN INSTITUTION IN
THE REGION THANKS HER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. THE MARGALLA HEALTH
AND FITNESS CENTER AT CENTRAL
CATHOLIC HIGH SCHOOL HONORS BOB
EMERY SON MARK. WHO DIED IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES FROM A RARE
DISEASE. THE HIGH SCHOOL ITSELF
IS ON LAND DONATED BY THE
GALLIVAN WE AS IS THE BEAUTIFUL
ST STANISLAUS CATHOLIC CHURCH
THE NEWEST AND LARGEST IN THE
STOCKTON DIVERS. THE ENTIRE
REGION IS DOTTED WITH THE
LEGACY OF MARIE'S PHILANTHROPIC
SPIRIT. THE AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST THE SALVATION ARMY. THE
CATHOLIC SOCIAL SERVICE GUILD
THE NATIONAL AGRICULTURAL
SCIENCE CENTER AND SO MANY MANY
MORE. I'M CLOSE ALL CLOSE WITH
THE WORDS OF THE DIOCESE ITSELF
WHICH SAID THE FOLLOWING. MARIE
GALLO WAS RAISED IN A HOME TO
STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
VIBRANT FAITH AND A
COMPASSIONATE HEART. SHE WAS
AND IS A STRONG EXAMPLE. OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO LIVE FOR
OTHERS. FOR MARIE THERE COULD
BE NO HIGHER COMPLIMENT. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. NAME IS GRAY
MISTER FLORA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
INTO AN ADJOURNMENT OF MARIE
GALLO I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MERCED TO BRING IN THIS MAJOR.
FOR THOSE OF US THE NUMERO- SHE
AN ABSOLUTE LIGHTNING- AND IT
SIR. IS A LAW DUMBER NOW THAT
SHE IS GONE. THIS USER BY A OF
WONDERFUL FAMILY GALLOPING
WHOSE BEEN SOCIAL ARE FOR SO
MANY YEARS. AND WE WHICH IS WHY
PUT OUR HEART AND TO THE- AND
JUST TO SAY THAT WE MISTER OF
WELL AND- WE DID LOSE A STRONG
LIKE FOR CAN. MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED AT THE GALA COULD ANY.
AND THEY CHOSE TO IT US TO
THEIR HOME AND FOR THAT WE ARE
ETERNALLY GRATEFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH FOR. MEMBER IT
RENAMES THE PREDATOR ALL
REQUESTS TO ADJOURN WILL BE
DEEMED AND MANAGER
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSIONS GET IS
THIS FOR MAY FOR NO SESSION-
CHECK. MONDAY MAY SEVENTH FLOOR
SO. IS A ONE M. YEAH MARC
BERKLEY GREAT. ALL OTHER
ADVISORY WE'VE RETAIN ALL SHE
BE CAN SAYING HEARING FOR THE
REST ALREADY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO. MS WALL MOOSE MISTER
MERCER SO. THAT IS HOW STANDS
UNTIL MONDAY MAY THE
SEVENTEENTH AT ONE PM WE ARE.